hello all I'm Chad Murray and we are
about to do some thirst tweets so get
your game face on Chad Michael Murray's
2005 nipples turned me gay have they
changed since 2005 so not 2019 nipples
but 2005 oh cool man
glad I paved the path appreciate it
brother I get credit sexuality Chad
Michael Murray licking his fingers be
thrown before throwing the football at
the end asunder other story I remember
that moment you know it's fun it's just
something yeah you do to make sure that
the leather sticks to your fingers when
he grabbed the ball now I can see how it
would have that effect on you
and I'm proud to say that I was you're
Madonna see Madonna for me was Oh
sexuality got it if you're gonna tell me
Chad Michael Murray wasn't your
childhood crush I don't want to be
friends with a liar
you tell him you defriend that person I
don't like liars either okay
it turns out just for everybody that she
will never be as horny for anyone as she
was for Chad and free fray even with the
hair even with the hair and my
incredible singing voice so the hair has
always been my choice by the way gone
through many many unfashionable trends
over the years and they're all my fault
thank you very much I appreciate it and
I'm sorry for all your future lovers
Chad Michael Murray and orgasm belong
under the same term in the dictionary so
do I get to put my face next to it in
the dictionary I know what my next art
piece in my home is gonna be if you
watch Riverdale you'll agree with me
when I say this Chad Michael Murray is
the definition of daddy would somebody
please bring me up on the daddy
definition saying daddy is like kind of
weird cuz you know that your dad so are
we saying that I can be the daddy of
your child that I understand
yeah you guys lost me on the day
anything now it's a it's got a Z in
front of it anyway like this is a D I
pretend that my body pillow is Chad
Michael Murray that's quite kind I
actually think that there probably is
one out there that you can find on
Amazon it's nice that Riverdale brought
a shirtless Chad Michael Murray back to
our screen well you know I thought went
in Rome everyone else was doing it you
know you got to fit in it's kind of not
fair right no I didn't competing with a
bunch of 20 year old guys who can you
know you make 30 hamburgers and I'm not
getting a pound still have a ten back I
would take Chad Michael Murray's jaw
line up for coffee well thank you very
much I am greatly appreciated about that
chin-ups everyday work some telling her
you
[Music]